all right so in chapter 2 the my hair is
doing like a a wave it's kind of neat
this is my eighth chapter to spoiler
talk if you've seen it chapter to
welcome stick around if you have it
spoiler warning I'm gonna spoil some
stuff some stuff that is for this
spoiler talk it's all spoiler talks it's
not a play-by-play this movie's three
hours long I'm not gonna tell you I'm
not gonna go buy everything that
happened in the movie but did that this
video would well in essence be about
three hours long or 20 minutes a kid
kind of I still like the movie but
there's some drawn-out stuff in it
anyhow this movie starts it actually
starts out with a hate crime where this
gay couple gets beaten up and thrown
over a bridge and then penny wise gets
to do it in the river and kills him he
eats him I actually do know that was
from the book which was actually an
important thing to showed not you know
for the hate crime but it was important
to show that penny wise is killing
adults too he'll kill adults I mean Ben
brought that up in it chapter one it's
like the death rate here is insane it's
worse for kids but adults as well so I
like that it showed Pennywise was like
nah I'll eat anybody who's scared out of
their mind then everyone gets the phone
call because Mike stayed behind and he's
all like alright guys what's happening
again and then I'll get the phone call
and now they're coming back they're
coming back to Derry I kind of skipped
over standing like it just Stanley at
the end cuz there's more to Stanley
Stanley kills himself because Stanley's
like that I'm not going back kind
of so I'll talk about Stanley at the end
which that first meetup was great
because that's when you see the
personalities coming through and you're
like oh so bill haters gonna crush it
that's what he's gonna he's talking
about Eddie's mom and he was like yeah I
mean your mom are very happy sometimes
she rolls over to me and goes cheese
sauce I can't do the job of the hut like
he did did they voice alter him or can
he just do that that well I remember any
impersonated Jabba the Hutt dying and
knocked up I can't even do with that
like keep his tongue was going back and
forth really fast I can't do that
ladies well yeah the rich is like I'm
leaving town before this ends worse than
one of bills books like they all just
want to leave I like Ron I'll stick
around but Mike has a plan he's like I'm
going to give bill some salvia and he's
just gonna trip balls which is that a
little route that he put in the drink
that specifically makes you trip balls
about Pennywise like he bill could have
he could have tripped about anything
are you seeing Pennywise no but I really
want to watch some Hendrix videos what
did you give me so it's pretty
remarkable that he got all the answers
about Pennywise that he was gonna get
and then he needed the butter is like
the trailer did it showed us some stuff
that it should have shown us granted
they showed us cool stuff also those
cool things would have been neat to see
in the movie like wouldn't the little
girls there's a little Firefly and it's
flying off I'm like oh that's when he
grabs it he goes hello I kind of felt
bad for him and that's he Pennywise like
my face and he's all like pathetic and
she's like I'll be your friend he just
had like that funhouse scene was great
but again in the trailer I saw the kid
in the trailer and then I was like oh
that's the kid bill keeps running into
and he kind of looks kind of creepy
because he's always running into this
kid and freaking out on if you like move
move from the stone this kids like
stranger danger alarms gotta be going
off hardcore but I recognized the kid
from the trailer but oh that's the kid
in the funhouse and that kid is
completely screwed he's not getting out
of that funhouse and sure enough
pennyways was beating his head against
the glass you know he starts doing the
Frank yeah you're the cyborg ninja from
Metal Gear Solid eats the kid
immediately just visually that was great
because the Bloods all bad and it's like
reflection blood reflection blood based
on how the lights hitting it basically
any scene where a child's being eaten
and murdered pretty sweet where else can
you say that except an it review it
sounds terrible it's not not true also
when I was giving props to the actors
what in my review of it chapter 2
totally skipped over Bill skarsgård I I
don't know I was just talking about the
grown-up kids the kids that are now
growing up in adult
bill skarsgård as great as penny wise up
and we find out this movie I penny wise
has been all these this group of Native
Americans they know about penny wise and
he's been terrorizing people I guess for
a long time he's been here for a few
million years I guess which I feel like
they could have done more with that
because Mike's all like there's an echo
we stopped it but it's echoed and comes
back in 27 years and the echoes back but
it's like every 27 years that why every
27 years does Pennywise come back to
Derry what do you mean echo and I feel
like they were eluding the stuff that I
just didn't go anyway that's for the end
of the movie to go back into that
crickety ask creepy house and I had
heard that some people found it very
repetitive in that house and I I didn't
at first and I saw the trailer again
because it's a crate trailer but yeah
watching it again there's the fridge
that shakes from the first one you got
the
three doors the three choices and all of
its from the first it
I guess when watching it I was like oh
that makes sense because that's what
freaked him out last time it's childhood
trauma of course it's gonna be what's on
their minds when they're in this place
so that's in turn what's going to
manifest but I can see how if you're
just watching it for the movies sake
it's like that's a little repetitive
it's the fact that you can make things
hurt Pennywise when it's just imaginary
the whole there so penny wise what I
gather anyway is that he makes your
fears come to life what is your thoughts
that come to life so like in Chapter one
when that thing that kills cows you know
the No Country for Old Men thing someone
uses it on penny wise they're like oh
it's not loaded and it goes click but
then penny wise reacts like it hurt him
because he believed it would hurt penny
wise so that's why it hurt penny wise a
penny wise makes your thoughts come to
life it's not just fear this movie does
it with a spear just like oh this hurts
monsters and that's the one thing they
actually use for that well that and you
know turning him into a little baby but
I thought they could have done so much
more with the concept of okay we can
make things killer weapons against this
thing just by believing that their
killer weapons I know it's hard there's
a difference between believing
something's real knowing something's
real and thinking it's real but knowing
it's not real so it's not really gonna
work it's tough but I just thought they
could have done more with that they
could have done more with a lot of
things in this movie they could have
done more with the bully that's back
he's been in the nut house I guess he he
lived falling down the well and then he
came out the sewer the other side and
then he's got arrested and he's he's
been in the loony bin now so penny wise
busts him out his kylo Ren looking
friend who died in it chapter one is his
driver now and he's going around and
does exactly jack in the movie he
stabs eddy in the cheek and he stabs him
in the chest and then Richard smashes
him in the head with an axe and then he
dies it could have done a lot more with
him to it don't know if that's how it is
in the book like I said my other review
if you if you're going to get on your
keyboard and type that's how it was in
the book please reference the beginning
of my it chapter to spoiler free review
so there were like many things in this
movie I felt like they could have done
much more with but maybe they were like
hey that'll make it like a five hour
movie even the flashback scenes with the
kids I felt like those were scenes that
were originally going to be in it
chapter one and they were like okay
we're coming up on three hours
all people are gonna sit through this
movie for three hours so let's make the
movie that's a little over two hours and
then if people like it then we'll make
it chapter two three hours long all the
flashback scenes would have been better
served in it chapter one but then again
without the flashback scenes you just
have a lot of adults hanging around to
town one of them trips balls then they
kind of find out what they need to do
they go down and turn him and do a
little baby head with little arms and
rip his heart out so it's for flow you
might need the flashback scenes that's
what happens before they turn him into a
baby let's just address the fact that
they go even deeper into Pennywise his
lair
and they see where he hid he landed and
there's the three floating balls and
Richie gets nailed by it which that
physical timing is ASIS it's amazing
there's like hippie calle mother it was
so good it's so hard to go from
energetic to just still so they realize
like wait what we believe to be reality
we can inflict on him so they basically
deal with Pennywise the way anyone
should deal with the twitter mob or
cancel culture if it comes after that
they just stand the ground they're like
you're nothing you don't have power over
us the only power you have is the power
we give you your tiny your small your a
little clown and he turns into a little
baby head with little baby arms he turns
into a little mushy baby and they rip
his heart out right in front of him we
crush it I did just like it's friendly
nice rip his heart out and crush it and
now Pennywise is gone
looks like forever the fact that they
haven't started forgetting that's a good
sign um do they immediately start
forgetting when they left Derry
immediately or did it take years I don't
know I will say those once seen when
they're in the arcade that Richie's in
the arcade and you see Mortal Kombat
there and I was like Mortal Kombat was
not released in the summer of 1989 it
was released in 1992 that was my moment
I know I said it out loud but definitely
that's how people were with like the
movie releases on the movie theater
people were like didn't have those
didn't come out their minds Mortal
Kombat we just look cuz if kids are
playing Mortal Kombat they're definitely
not playing Street Fighter 1 they're
playing Street Fighter 2
there was no leap from Street Fighter 2
Mortal Kombat with Street Fighter 2
completely missing the boat yeah the end
Stan Lee is dead because he killed
himself rather than go back to Darion so
like for Stan Lee's suicide it was
basically bill gets this note and it's
like hey I had to
do what I did to bring you all together
which I really didn't feel I didn't feel
like they all stuck together because
Stanley killed himself it's kind of
nuanced in there a little bit but I
don't feel like it was necessary in the
end just like this guy kills himself
which I feel like it's more powerful to
be like this guy would rather kill
himself than break his promise and not
go back or go back he doesn't want to do
either so he's just gonna kill himself
but instead they like he made the great
sacrifice for Humanity Stanley there's
just a weird way to push it and I would
have preferred it just stayed well
Stanley was just scared out of his mind
because Pennywise like kind of tried to
eat his head last time when he was a kid
I wouldn't want to go back either
Eddie's dead Eddie actually took that
hit pretty well I could stab through the
back and he's actually alive for a while
he's alive a lot longer than I thought
someone couldn't be alive with that
wound that wounds being basically he got
the Bishop from aliens dude he was in
bad shape I mean mine is being ripped in
half
that didn't happen I still a solid hit
he took Ritchie told him he is stronger
than he thinks and it was proven right
by staying alive for longer than half a
second after he gotten bailed through
the back now kumbaya jump in the lake I
was like is this cheesy I'm kind of
getting the feels though because it
really was Bill Hader crying that
brought it home for me in that scene and
Ben got the girl hell yeah yeah in the
end I enjoyed it Chapter two I enjoyed
it chapter two like I said it's like
this companion piece to it chapter one I
can't just pop in at chapter two and
just watch it for the of it like I
can it chapter one I need to like
Bueller I want a marathon the whole
thing it chapter one at chapter 2 just
going right through it we have a solid
it saga that's not really scary but
super cool alright so it chapter two
again I'll ask you all I can ask you is
have you seen it what did you think
about it I can't be like woah what's
different from the book what did you
like that they change that spoilers for
me at this point
I plan on finishing that book before
2030 right now I jumped on the
novelization of Star Wars Episode 7
known as heir to the Empire the true
Star Wars Episode 7 at this point as far
as I'm concerned so Star Wars heir to
the Empire by Timothy Zahn have you read
it watch it you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]